and we begin with this for the first
time uber is confirming thousands of
sexual assaults involving its passengers
and drivers in a new report the
ride-sharing company says about three
thousand assaults were reported last
year alone and more than 200 of those
were allegations of rape CBS this
morning national correspondent Jericka
Duncan is with us Jericka good morning
what else does this report reveal well
Tony this report revealed that uber says
there were hundreds of reports of
attempted rape and more than a thousand
reports of non-consensual touching uber
maintains that a very small percentage
of its total rides were affected a
company spokesperson says uber is
committed to transparency and taking
concrete steps to address these problems
in its long anticipated safety report
uber which was responsible for 1.3
billion rides last year took an
unprecedented look into reported sexual
assaults if you want to improve
something you have to measure it
Uber's Brooke Anderson says the report
was necessary for both customers and the
company the public has a right to know
and secrecy about the hardest issues
that we face doesn't make anyone safer
in the two years they measured 2017 in
2018 there were nearly six thousand
reports of sexual assault involving
passengers and drivers these are some
some very alarming figures fed Siddiqui
is a technology reporter at the
Washington Post he says the numbers are
significant for uber and for the entire
ride sharing industry that's a large
number it suggests that there is a huge
societal problem or extension of a
societal problem that's happening on our
ride hailing trips uber and rival
ride-sharing service lift have faced
harsh criticism in lawsuits for not
doing enough to protect the safety of
riders most recently dozens of women are
suing lyft serious safety incidents are
exceptionally rare and in fact 99.9
percent of trips and without any safety
issue at all but I think it's also a
reflection of the responsibility we have
to constantly improve safety on our
platform uber says it's rolling out new
safety features that will allow riders
to verify their driver with a secure PIN
code
send a text message directly to 900
operators and report safety incidents to
ooh BRR before their trip is even over
uber CEO Derek Haas Raja he tweeted
doing the right thing means counting
confronting and taking action to end
sexual assault CBS News spoke with him
about the issue in September we're not
perfect I wouldn't claim to be perfect
but I believe that we're significantly
better than we were last year and next
year darn it we're gonna be better
you're seeing two reactions to sides who
say it's absolutely shocking that this
number is now out there and it's in the
thousands and then you have another side
that says but it's good that the company
is coming clean about it
a spokesperson for uber says the company
plans to share driver deactivation
information with other ride-sharing
companies to make sure when a driver is
kicked off ooh BRR for safety violation
other companies are also made aware but
uber reps say drivers are also victims
to making up a significant portion of
those saying they were sexually
assaulted regardless of who the
aggressor is uber says it will
permanently ban any user found to have
committed an assault
I mean s injures assaulting drivers yeah
yeah I mean we've seen it on camera you
know a lot of times they have mailed
passengers assaulting females well it's
not necessarily male or female but I
think Google was making the point that
sometimes you have the writers that are
assaulting the driver it goes both ways
yeah but by and large they recognize
their job is to help keep people safe
but it is a risk you take when you think
back to 20 years ago the idea of getting
in a car with a stranger
yes something you couldn't even fathom I
think they're coming on I think it's
thanks for showing us that they're
working on it then to your point about
getting in a car you I used to think
child lock or a good idea especially
when you have little kids yeah now I'm
really curious I think about it now when
I get it if you're in the backseat yes
you are trapped like a rat with nowhere
to go before you you get in there yeah
yeah Thank You jury Co thank you my turn